so the machine has now got to try to
destroy Tim Scott so Chris Cuomo who
stepped down from Seattle was fired from
CNN in shame apparently he's got some
show again and he had Cleveland
representative Nina Turner on and she's
a major race huckster and well don't
take my word for it here she is do you
think he has the ability to reach into
voters of color and say I don't care
what party you're for be for me
well of course one black face in a high
place does not mean that systemically
black people in America are not still
suffering so one you can attempt to be a
Unity candidate but the best way to be a
Unity candidate is by telling the truth
lying about this country's country
country's history gets you nowhere and I
am definitely appalled that Senators
Scott that he would even say something
like that one black face does not
people these people they you see they
they resent people who get out there and
get theirs and become successful and do
things every young black person should
be looking at Tim sky going man look
what this guy's accomplished and now
he's running for president how freaking
awesome how freaking awesome looking at
Larry Elder how freaking awesome the
Litany of people but every time that a
black person succeeds it is the leftist
machine and the people who have been
duped by it that try to destroy them
foreign
[Music]